folks the right has a new meme i don't
know
if mass formation psychosis
is completely killing let's go brandon
but it is spreading rapidly
on the virus front we have omicron
rapidly out competing delta
on the memetic front right wing memes
we quickly have mass formation psychosis
overwhelming let's go brandon they can
probably co-exist
what i'm what am i talking about mass
formation psychosis let me set this up
for you
there's this guy called robert malone
robert malone is someone who
has for a period of time now been
credited with and taken credit for
developing mrna vaccine technology now
this is a claim that has been fact
checked quite a bit
it's a bit of an exaggeration what the
right wingers want you to believe
is that robert malone
is the guy who created
mrna vaccination and now he's totally
against it and thinks it's terrible and
dangerous and wants to destroy the
monster he created and remember all this
different stuff okay
a more sober analysis and you can just
google
a number of different
very good stories about this is that he
was one of many people
over a long period of time
who did research that contributed
to the development of the technology
which of course eventually can get
applied to one thing or another and now
a couple of the current covet vaccines
are based
on the mrna okay you get the idea right
so so
that's part number one
the second part is robert malone
has now been uh banned from twitter for
spreading
covet disinformation
and this is of course bringing out all
of the
that's fascism
and communism
and authoritarianism and it's violation
of free speech and all these different
so it's bringing out those people
it's also bringing out the people who
are of the mindset of the the truth
trademark the truth about covet vaccines
and covet itself
is being suppressed it's being covered
up etc etc
so robert malone got himself an
appearance on an emergency podcast with
joe rogan
and in it he
i don't know that he coined the term but
he kind of made a portmanteau of two
terms that exist and that term is mass
formation psychosis he is saying that
this
mob psychosis plagues
um
the side of science when it comes to
covet and what is incredible i mean this
clip has gone giga viral millions upon
millions of views
when you listen to what he's saying it
sounds like he's explaining what is
plaguing the american right wing the
covid deniers the vaccine conspiracists
the trumpers the stop the stealers but
he's not talking about that let's just
get right into the clip and then we're
going to talk about it listen really
closely from
basically european intellectual inquiry
into what the heck happened in germany
in the 20s and 30s you know very
intelligent highly educated population
and they went barking mad
and how did that happen
the answer is mass formation psychosis
when you have a society that has become
decoupled from each other and has
free-floating anxiety in a sense that
things don't make sense
we can't understand it and then their
attention gets focused by a leader or
series of events guys he's describing
trumpism
what we have i mean it's
do
i almost feel like i i'm over it's
it's too on the nose like i i feel like
if i give any explanation i'm over
explaining
it sounds like he's describing the mass
psychosis of trumpism that i've been
talking about for years but he's not
he's talking about people who accept the
vaccine science on one small point just
like hypnosis
they literally become hypnotized and can
be led anywhere
and yeah and 70 something million of
them ended up voting for trump one of
the aspects of that phenomena is the
people that they identify as their
leaders the ones typically that come in
and say you have this pain and i can
solve it for you i and i alone
guys he's quoting trump
he's
he's quoting trump here is here is trump
literally sang
i alone can fix it i alone can fix it i
will restore
law and order to our country do you guys
remember that
it he's quoting trump verbatim but we're
supposed to believe
it's the
you know i don't want to call it the
left because there's republicans that
accept science and in paris
i've never seen anything like this okay
can fix this problem for you okay then
they will lead they will follow that
person yeah it doesn't matter whether
they lie to him or whatever that's
exactly what happened with trump he lied
to them about all of it i mean it's
how does
it
now they're all on this now all the
right wingers now yeah doc robert malone
explained what's going on with these
leftists this mass format
the data are irrelevant and furthermore
anybody who questions
that narrative right is to be
immediately attacked they hear the
this is central to mass formation
psychosis and this is what has happened
we had all those conditions if you
remember back before
2019 everybody was complaining the world
doesn't make sense blah blah blah
um and we're all isolated from each
other we're all in our little tools
we're not connected socially anymore
except through social media there's
something about these types of typically
it's it's guys where they talk in a
certain way
i mean
where they they do what they're accusing
that when he talks about hypnosis
what you when you listen to the way that
brett weinstein has spoken about
vaccines he goes
well the um
it's uh
spike protein is cytotoxic and i i'm
concerned that lis they have a way of
talking
and ben shapiro has it too although it's
a different way very different way of
talking
where it almost doesn't matter what they
say now what the now they're all talking
about mass formation psychosis what is
that
um this is a combination the term mass
formation psychology is a pre-existing
term and it just means like crowd or mob
psychology and they're just saying he's
adding psychosis to it to say well it's
a form of psychosis it's a mass it's a
mob psychosis of sorts
um
what is incredible about this is that we
have to share this because this is the
best description i've ever heard of the
maga movement
except he's not applying it to that when
i listen to it i'm thinking
wow what a
what a perfect analysis of what has
plagued this country
with the maga movement for years now
but he's not talking about that like the
the unaware lack of awareness about the
irony is incredible now just because you
come up with a name for something
doesn't mean it accurately describes
anything and the truth is i've been
describing what's going on since kovid
in this way
for a long time you know back in january
of last year 2021 i did a segment called
the shared psychosis of trumpism i mean
i i literally described this except he's
he's describing it but not actually
talking about trumpism in may of last
year i did a segment called 54 of
republicans
think trump riots were led by violent
left-wing protesters where i described
this
as a group psychosis that's verbatim the
word that i used so it's not a new
concept and it couldn't be more of an
instance of projection but this is their
new meme
robert malone is their new hero
and the new meme is mass formation
psychosis and they lack the ability
or awareness to realize it applies to
them better than to anybody else they
might point the finger at send me your
thoughts uh you can find me on twitter
at d pacman curious to hear from you
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple people are busy
we're not always getting effective
balanced nutrition from the food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food-sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality
bio-available ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes